Oh shit, that's the World Cup thing.
Give me a sec.
Let me swap this.
I forgot.
I forgot I had the World Cup stuff.
This was my alleyway background.
There we go.
I was just like, why are we in the, not the World Cup guys.
Not, it's tomorrow.
That's tomorrow, guys.
Okay, where's my, there you go.
up hello everybody hello hello today uh we are a little
dirty today we're brokey today because i woke up to you know
i woke up you know i thought it was over you know when the
tournament ended i'm like bye everybody bye and then we move
on um so apparently some people didn't move on
so I woke up to a lot of drama
but you know who didn't wake up to a lot of drama sure for
like
sure for it was like as if he never existed because he was
on his fucking tisumi account so people were like you know
people were just looking at it are like oh yeah you know
they see tisumi they he has he actually five brain he is
like five lame 5d chess so no one really knows he was
actually there or not because like people were just looking
at them screenshots would just see to sue me I should have
gotten in with not dokey brain I should have used a not
dokey brain account he's getting nobody knew sure for what's
part of this he's so fucking smart
Like no one had said anything I was sure for just because he
like don't like even use his actual account And he was like
trying to be quiet for mode.
He's so smart.
I should have been just like him
Um Anyway, this is why I'm a little guy right now because It
we're good because like we're gonna talk a little bit about
the little drama to keep people who don't know what's going
on You can't be mad at me if I'm just a little guy, you
know, like I put in all the manipulation tactics and like
Can't be mad at me with this little face
You cannot be angry a little guy All right, which is cuter,
guys Hood on Hood on or no hood, guys, which is cuter I'm
trying to I'm trying to like survive here
This little dokey cat do no harm
No, I just It's crazy It's not really addressed to me There
were like one or two About it But it was just I was like
what fuck me for
I'm trying to But, yeah, it's not really me.
It's more so it was like, it was like, it's like turned into
an Overwatch versus a Marvel Rivals war right now.
Bring Dad in there.
Oh, you're right.
Can't be at me and my dog, right?
Look at me.
I'm just hanging out with my dog.
Can't be mad at both of us.
Yeah.
So it was more so like it turned into a console.
war somehow uh yeah it turned into a like everyone's getting
involved all the well i don't know which other overwatch
creator got involved but it was like almost all the marvel
rivals creators and then uh got involved and it turned into
like overwatch versus marvel rivals and i was just like i
was like what happened i woke up i was like what happened
like i felt like i was Troy from community and i'm just like
i got pizza guys but then like then they like dragged me
into the fight too and i'm like what did i do i'm just a
little guy i said ggs everybody i said
so yeah it's it's a little rough out there right now
I like both games.
I, you know, I'm like, I love Overwatch and Rivals.
And I'm like, oh my God, can I even, oh my God, will I be
able to stream Overwatch anymore?
I don't know.
I was like, by association, I'm, since I was in Team Canada,
I'm like, oh no, but I love both games.
I love Overwatch and Rivals.
Don't make me choose.
It's like a divorce.
Apex?
Like, mommy and daddy needs you right now to tell us who you
want to stay with.
I was like, but I want to stay with both of you.
Your fence sitter, Doki.
Pick a side.
Like, but can I go to grandma's?
Can I go to grandma Apex?
Yeah.
Can I go to grandma Apex's place?
They were It's like a bitter divorce Between Overwatch and
Marvel Rivals Like Or Uncle Deadlock I don't want to go to
Uncle Deadlock's place He smells weird Yes
But yeah It was crazy too Because I was like I saw like one
clip where like I was named drop and they're and it was like
about the did you remember the Deadpool tournament with
Tyler 1 and Moxie and then um trying people were like oh
she's the she was like me and Fan Fan were also part of the
problem and I'm like what did Fan Fan and I do like I was
like we tried her best on support I thought we tried her
best and I was like what the clip I saw that meant me and I
was like, what did I, what did I, what did I, our team got
third, didn't we?
We got, we got fucking destroyed by Calvin.
Yeah, I remember the hell up, like the hell on X's team, but
like that was just poor bad line.
Yeah.
It was like, it was just poor bad line, you know, and like
we still got, we didn't get last.
We were, we were third.
I'm pretty sure we're third or fourth.
I don't third right so i was like i don't think i was part
of the problem during the deadpool tournament i felt like i
did my job i thought i was doing really well in the deadpool
tournament yeah and then and then like and then people were
like and then i saw one where it was like um i was like
being blamed for asking to swap to asking to swap but i was
just like didn't i i don't remember how i only asked once
right i was like oh there's a flanking star lord um can we
have a hit scan and then sure for was like oh i'm on
wolverine i can't play hit scan right now so that was like
okay uh can we swap boring to to hit scan so we can shoot
the star lord and i think that was the only time i said if
we could swap like during the matches yeah and I was like,
why fuck me for?
I wasn't even feeling negative about it.
I thought I was being, like, constructive about it.
Yeah.
I thought, so I was just like, oh my god.
Hello?
Hello, everyone.
I'm just a little guy.
I said, I said, GG's, everybody.
like yeah and so like i was just like but it was more so
like fan fan and i were just like the you know like the the
what is it called like just straight bullets hitting us too
yeah and then i were just like the straight bullets that
coincidentally also hit us and then surefire fucking came in
with Tissumi.
Yeah, the collateral damage.
Yeah, we were collateral damage.
So, yeah, it's just fucking Tissumi.
The Tissumi account.
I even, like, after the tournament, I even sent Warren a DM
being like, hey, I'm sorry.
Like, you know, like, you don't deserve what's going on with
the internet right now.
and everything and I was like I try to like privately talk
to me like you don't deserve it and stuff and um everyone
should just move on and it's like go next like I think I was
like bro like yeah it was just it was just unbalanced I was
just it was just unbalanced like we all made mistakes and
then so now I was just like I was like I woke up to more
drama I was just like what happened
I was just like, what happened?
I thought we all said GGs.
What was it?
No, okay, so I saw people mentioning this.
I don't even know if I'm going to get, I don't know.
I think everybody's clipping everything right now, but I'm
on YouTube.
So I'm just like, I don't think people are paying attention
to me.
But this was the timeline for the fan fan.
think also i don't think he saw my dm because like he left
the server instantly and i try to friend him on discord but
he doesn't accept friend requests so i dm did on twitter so
i don't know i don't think he saw it um but fan fan was
shroud's last minute replacement um the timeline was that we
all knew half the roster uh on the 12th so almost two weeks
ago yeah it was literally two weeks ago the organizers who
the people were on Team Canada and they were like it's gonna
be me, XQC, Warren, Aramori and Fanfan so that this was all
these were the confirmed these were the confirmed roster and
this was all the way on the 12th but we didn't have a server
that we got the server like I think like four to five days
before the tournament I think I don't know maybe it was
three to four days before the tournament.
That's, uh, that was our, uh, uh, that was when we all got
in a server together.
And, uh, well, it was just X was the last person to get in
the server.
X got in the server on the day of the tournament.
Um, and, uh, Sure4 replaced Fan Fan on the 16th.
Um, I know this because, um, I asked Sure4 about it because,
like, he joined the server and I was like,
like yeah I was just like you're not on the roster list how
did you get in here and he was like oh I was asked on the
16th uh and I was like wait who told you was on the team on
the 16th and he was like oh it was it was going to be you uh
all I was told was XQC and Shroud was going to be on the
team so I was like oh okay so Shroud was confirmed on since
the 16th at least so that's what I knew Fan-Fan dropped out
and then Shurefort replaced Fan-Fan.
So it was going to be...
So on the 16th, we knew it was going to be me, XQC, Warren,
Aramori, Shurefort, and Shroud.
And then on the day of the announcement, we found out Shroud
had to drop out.
And Fan-Fan came back as an emergency sub on the day of the
announcement, which was the day before the tournament.
But that was our fully confirmed roster.
was going to be well i knew the roster i don't know if the
others knew what the full roster was but i asked my manager
asked because you know we're curious so we knew me and my
manager knew the roster since the 12th was going to be me
xqc warren aramori and fanfan and then like i said fanfan
dropped out sure forward play fanfan on the 16th shroud got
picked up around the 16th um and then yeah and then shout
dropped out on a day of the announcement and then fanfan
came back as an emergency sub so that that's the whole
timeline like that was the whole timeline of everything so
it was a bit it was a bit of a cluster fuck because like um
you know i was like who's on our team
Um, I talked to the devs too, because I was like, I felt bad
for them, because, you know, I was like, I'm sorry, I was, I
told the devs, I was like, I'm sorry about all the drama,
because, you know, they don't, you know, they, they are,
they're trying their best to, like, you know, it's, they're,
we're all humans, we're all people, like, you know, and,
like, we all make mistakes and stuff, so, you know, I even
went to the devs, I was like, I'm sorry for all the drama,
like, I'm sorry, you guys have to go through more drama,
like,
yeah and so i felt you know i felt bad for everyone involved
i felt bad for the people in the world cup too because like
this was supposed to be a big shining moment to content
creators from around the world and shining like a spotlight
on content creators from around the world because there's a
lot of like unknowns from around the world like everyone was
like oh usa canada are strongest but i knew when because i
was looking at the players individually we had the most well
known streamers yes but it doesn't mean we were the
strongest i knew that latin latin america had the strongest
team because individual wise they're they are better players
so i was because like people don't know but the thing is
people didn't know these creators around like overall and
globally people didn't know those players globally but now
they do because they're like wait these players are actually
really really good but I felt so bad for the players um in
the World Cup tournament because everyone's just gonna talk
about the drama now like I just I just feel so bad because
like yeah like it fucking sucks like I felt like it ended up
shadowing a tournament where a lot of these streamers and
content creators are seeing this as like their next big
break and also it's a lot of fucking money for them
especially when it's like it's so um converting to like you
know people like the currency in asia or like in latin
america um it's yeah and like brazil practice really fucking
hard too as well and then the fact that like you know they
are getting so that these creators are getting a lot of
money out of this and they're missing out on a lot of
positive exposure and i feel really bad about it because the
drama is now in the mean focus and not the participants in
the world cup that uh like the smaller creators and the, um,
and the under, like underrepresented regions who don't,
might not have a lot of eyes on them before, like globally,
you know, globally, they might not have been like really
known before, uh, before this tournament.
And now like, I, you know, out of all this, I feel like the
world, like I feel really bad for just like the creators in
the World Cup tournament, just because of how, you know,
everyone's going to be talking about the drama now instead
of the World Cup and like now there's so much negativity
around surrounding the World Cup that no one's really gonna
pay attention to like you know the other teams that are
still in there you know the tournament was going on still
like uh like tomorrow like tomorrow tomorrow's the finals
and I'm just I hope like people still watch the finals um
watch the finals and still support the teams that qualified
in the World Cup and everything.
I think that should be the most important thing where we
should focus on the positive side of the teams that did
qualify, the players that worked really, really hard to be
there to get to the finals too.
Yeah, like, I just, I legitimately woke up and was like,
what's all of this?
Oh my God, wait, I even, I'm sorry.
I even saw people were like, why are the supports KD like
pushed, you know, like doing screenshots and me like, why
are the supports KD lower than everyone else?
And I'm like, we're supports when he was, we were trying to
save, we're trying.
That's all I can say.
Fembe and I, we were trying.
If I ever tried to DPS, like, by myself, like, if I try to
go to a Flake Luna, my entire team will die.
I literally tried it one time where I looked away one time
and then X died because I wasn't healing him.
And I was like, well, I can't look away anymore.
I, like, I was like, oh my God.
can't look away i have to keep pumping heels i can't do you
guys remember that i looked away one time and then he was
dead he was fucking dead yeah yeah yeah so i was just like
i'm sorry guys because people were i feel like bad about it
we did really the best we could in the situation We were in
so I was just like When they were saying like why didn't the
Supports have more kills And I was like have so little kills
And I'm just looking at Fan Fan and I'm like you know like
The whale the whale picture
You know like The whale picture where The guy like looks at
And he's like this is us This is me and Fan Fan and like we
were like Why fuck us I don't understand Wait, let me find
the picture.
The whale meme.
This is...
Is it this picture?
Yeah, this is me and Fan Fan.
They're like, why did Captain America live for so long?
Me and Fan Fan looking at each other.
This...
the me and fan fan look at each other
they're like i don't know what do we do but
if this was us during like i was just like what do you want
us to do guys what do you it's like it's so funny like
that's us i'm so tired
they don't say anything i think that's what's happened
throughout the tournament me and faba just stopped saying
anything we were just we were just like faba disappeared for
like during the breaks dude like she left the call to reset
herself yeah yeah they don't see they just look at you like
this yeah even our coach abandoned us
wanted to say about it i just thought like i was i did not
expect the drama to to blow up like that like the the team
canada situation got pretty bad guys but i didn't ask the
death i was like i think you could put my knee i was like
can i get it do you if you do this again can i get And then
the dev was like the devs were like dude.
Yeah, dude.
We'll give you a redemption arc I was like yay I don't know
if I'll get it, but you know, it doesn't hurt to ask you
know like the team Canada situation is wild, you know, I put
my name in there.
I put my name in there for to get a re a rerun, you know,
what was it called?
What's the word?
A run back.
Yeah.
Guys, season two has been renewed.
Yeah, we got a season two, guys.
Let's hope it doesn't get canceled because of the World Cup
trauma.
And rivals never did another World Cup again, guys.
We're going to run it back.
Guys, guys, I think season two might get canceled.
I think season two might get canceled, guys.
there was never a world cup yeah i just i think i like i
said out of all of this i just feel really bad for the
remaining teams um that uh made it to the finals just
because like i felt like there could have you know i feel
like they definitely they definitely deserve the positive
exposure Especially Team Japan.
I heard Team Japan apparently was really fun to watch too.
Because people didn't believe in Team Japan at first.
People were actually like, you know what's crazy?
I remember seeing the tweets in my algorithm.
Yeah, I wish there was more.
I hope they do get a spotlight on Sunday.
But anyway, Team Japan.
I remember when the teams were announced.
People were like, wait, are they all support players?
But they actually were like a really good team.
They were basically second place in their groups.
yeah they were really fun to watch and everything and their
players it was just really fun like they were all like
having fun and enjoying each other's like they were all
group of friends just playing together and they got second
place um in in their group too so like uh so i like hope
that the spotlight will still the spotlight would still like
be on them on uh i hope the the spotlight will still be on
them um for uh sunday in the end and i that's the only thing
i feel like i feel really bad about regarding all of the
drama that's going on because i really do feel like um they
do this like a lot of these players are also very small a
lot of them are smaller content creators too as well i think
it was like team canada and us had like i think really big
content creators within it um not just in uh in canada
america but also in you know brazil and latin america like
latin america united and but there were a lot of very
smaller content creators as well um scattered around all the
different regions and i really would hope that they also get
the spotlight that they deserve but yeah that's like my
final thoughts on it um i you know no one deserves to be uh
to be like you know what's the word paled on on the internet
like it's not a great feeling um overall and you know um i i
had no hate to anybody on my team i i said that on the last
on my last stream too like please don't say any hate to my
teammates and everything like we were all just put in a
really tough situation and um you know we all tried our best
like i don't i want to say like no one tried like everybody
tried the best the best they could with what we were given
and it was just you know our team was just was just
unbalanced and like um and it was just really hard yeah it
was just we we had just had a very unfortunate situation for
our team yeah and you know we tried the best we could given
the situation we were in like uh but yeah that's i guess
that's everything i wanted to say i don't think there's much
for me to add on i think um i i feel i just feel really bad
for it that the drama blew up that i woke up and i was like
my my algorithm was just all of it i mean i had fun on the
last game the last game was fun were when we were all like
let's get final hits guys yeah let it ride i had fun there
yeah it was i think our last game was the best game we've
had because we all i thought we all started bonding guys i
legitimately thought we all started bonding on the last game
like and i woke up tomorrow and then like i hate all of you
like like like and then i'm like guys were we not bonding as
a family
yeah i was like i thought we were all friends guys I thought
we all started bonding Yeah, I think it was like Me and
Surefour, FanFan, and X just They'd be like What happened?
What happened?
I thought we trauma bonded Guys, you know I was right I was
right, remember at the end Yeah, I was like Did we not
trauma bond together Everyone?
Did we not?
when we thought trauma bonded and yeah and i i thought it
was uh really funny that it's i still think it was really
funny i sure for god like basically nothing happened to him
because he was on fucking to sue me like trauma bonding is
not bonding but yeah it's just we're like whatever What's
going on?
And then it turned into a console war where now it's like
Marvel Rivals versus Overwatch.
And I'm like, but I love both games.
Please don't make me choose.
Please don't make me go back to Granny Apex.
Yeah.
The drama did not find.
Um.
Anyway, yeah, I don't know what else to say.
Other than that, it's not the cons.
It's the cons of wars all over again.
I like it.
I love Apex, but I'm like, I can't just only play Apex,
guys.
Like, how did they not know that Shorfer?
Who was it?
Was it Aramori or Warren that was like, who's to sue me?
I don't remember who said that, but I know it was either
Aramori or Warren that was like, wait, who's this to sue me
person here?
And I was like, you guys don't know Tatsumi?
It's the classic.
Yeah, I don't remember who it was.
I was like, Tatsumi's OG Shure 4 Alt account.
It's literally her anime, like his anime girl.
But I forgot who it was that said that.
I have Deadlock.
I've had Deadlock since the closed beta.
I just never...
Yeah, they don't know the Shure 4 lore.
But I don't remember who it was.
them that said that so that's like people don't remember the
og sure for lord like the the very like one of the first
sure for alt accounts it was tisumi and people would think
it wasn't like a girl like a girl's name so he would like
pretend to be an anime girl on tisumi his very first alt
account and his emotes are all based off of the tisumi
that's what tisumi looks like that's his tisumi persona
that's his that's who his emotes are based off of i used to
watch sure for it i you guys back in the overwatch days um i
watched a lot of streamers and sure for was like one of the
biggest overwatch streamers back in the day before like al
was a thing and i used to watch sure for a lot so it was i
was like i couldn't believe i became friends with that guy
like because i actually used to watch and it was like i
became friends with him when i was a corp of youtuber too
not like before then too like that's only when i met him
because i was like asking for overwatch was doing and sure
for was like hey i'm down and i was like holy i was like
sure for and then yeah and i got killed on him now look at
us i got him killed on the bridge yeah now we're homies he's
like is he sure for yeah now he's my babysitter someone i
used to watch became my life is so unpredictable guys like
look at us did you look at us cheer for and he's just like
regrets every choice he's made where it led to me in his
path like yeah truly a story for the age life is unfair like
he regrets every decision he made that put me in his path
Before and after, don't keep it.
Um, but yes, other than that, in conclusion, drama sex.
That's that.
I mean, honestly, what else can I say?
Gus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Gus, people say never meet your heroes.
For sure, for it.
It's never meet your fans.
Post-traumatic stress joki It's too late Oops, too late Now,
now we're bonded Now I'll forever be in your path Until he
dies Not me though, I'll live forever I'm uploaded into the
web My consciousness is already uploaded into the web So
I'll live him Also, because he's, like, much older.
He's an unc.
Yeah.
But, yeah.
I'm pretty sure it's gonna, people are gonna forget it in,
like, tomorrow.
Okay, not tomorrow.
But, like, I'll give it a week.
Drama, I don't know if you guys noticed, but Marvel Rivals
had, like, I think, like, three dramas within a week now.
So, and, like, I don't think people even remembered the last
three dramas that happened.
like within the last week i don't even think people
remembered what the fuck happened yeah by next week it's
gonna be forgotten it's like flavor of the week you know
flavor of the month games this is the flavor of the week
drama oh yeah yeah no there's been like it's i think like
from what i could recall there was like there was like
beefing between two like flats and light or something i
don't know i vaguely saw it on my timeline i was like what
the fuck is going on there's like beefing between flats and
light um another over another rivals tournament drama that
happened earlier and then uh oh yeah the the sinna
tournament drama that happened and like people forgot about
that already um the kingsman versus jitward the charge
exclamation point charge uh dream thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you so if you guys didn't know rivals
did like an event where um you you base it's basically a
battle of the streamers and um and like people in chat just
has to do exclamation point charge um to uh get points so
it's like whoever's chat fan base is stronger um and it's
more active like you get more points and then people started
botting it apparently like macroing the exclamation point
charge thing so like it was against like Jitward and
Kingsman because they were both accused of botting
apparently and King Jitward was like yeah he's botting and
uh but like and I'm botting too but I know he's botting so
why isn't he bad because Jitward got banned off the
leaderboard and um and then Jitward called Kingsman out on
him being like if I'm gotta be bad you should be banned too
like you know and I think that was it and then Kingsman was
like I'm not botting you're the one that's botting and then
that was and then they both posted like and Jitward posted
and I think like a chat GPT like analysis graph research
thing and then Kingsman posted Google Dockey against Jitward
as well with like screenshots and everything and the
mutually assured destruction yeah and then kings was like
was like was like i'm not botting you're the one that's
botting and it was like well i i might be botting i might
not be botting but i know what a bot thing looks like so
it's like it's like it was weird i don't know i don't know
who's botting i don't know if they're botting or not but i
thought the fucking mind games were like i don't i'm not
botting but i know what body is so i i know your body yeah i
just i don't know i don't know who's body i don't know maybe
they're both body who the fuck knows anyway um so so why is
it like because like the prize was 500 subs um and for
whoever wins first and second place and wait let me sorry my
intercom went off because i was getting my jolly bees and so
uh so i didn't want to talk while i was getting my like you
know he'll be like hearing my stream through the intercom um
what was i oh yeah so it's 500 subs and that's like what
like two grand or something right is that two grand i don't
remember i don't know how much i don't stream on twitch that
often is in general for like on Twitch so um so it's a lot
of money yeah 2,500 it's a lot of money so then people and
then people were like why does Kingsman need the money like
he already has so much money and then like give it to
Jitward he's just a little guy and so there was like that
and then like he was like what the fuck like that little guy
is botting and then the little guy was like And then people,
he was like, yeah, I just want to, you know, I want to win,
you know, I'm competitive.
He was like, I want to win, I'm competitive.
I want to be the top rank.
Like, it's just, I don't know.
It's just, I thought the whole thing was pretty funny.
But, like, as an outsider, you know, as someone looking into
it, like, yeah, as an outsider looking into the situation,
pretty funny like single-minded thank you the super chat
thank you thank you don't say remember from Marvel Rivals
this week is Daredevil swimsuit outfit came on apparently
has a third one been on him thank you the super chat thank
you say oh my gosh which reminded me not your super chat by
the way nothing related to your super chat by the way yeah I
thought oh my god I really I was because I was like browsing
through and just seeing like the arguments about it and some
people were like uh those streamers in team canada don't
need that money anyway so who cares if they got last place
like you still get you're a rich streamer and i was like
sometimes you know yes we do get free money yeah i was like
it's all right even we got last you know i did say even on
the on the on the last stream i was like it's all right i
mean you it's free money i like whatever we got last we
still got free money you know we still had i thought we
bonded i thought we trauma bonded in the end maybe half of
us did half of us trauma bonded in the end yeah yeah but
then i was like i was thinking like some you know it's nice
to not be last place though it's nice to you know the thing
the reason why i do tournaments i don't do i i will say like
for the turn the reason why i joined so many tournaments is
i love the tournament experience i love um i love being
competitive and i love like you know doing well in
tournaments too like i'm a competitive person as well and
that's why i joined tournaments i like like i'm used to
losing i'm i've like i've lost tournaments i've won
tournaments i've done in the i've been in the middle of
tournaments so like i can go gg go next very easily because
there's always so many eventually you win a tournament like
if you keep joining tournaments eventually you win that's
what i learned because i kept doing that yeah and um and
that's the reason why i do it it just it sucks to be last
place i've been last place before and um and it's like
people who make the argument being like oh these rich
streamers these rich streamers are so greedy they just want
more money And I was like, I just want to do well.
I think all of us in Teen Canada wanted to do well.
I don't think any of us were like, we're like, yeah, last
place.
We all didn't want to, because it looks bad on all of us.
And we were representing Canada.
Like, it looks bad on all of us.
So I think all of us tried our best, like, given what we
had.
Losing's not fun.
Yeah.
Going and winning couldn't be me.
I, like, we all don't want to lose.
But, but yeah, anyway.
I know I said this is the last time I talked, but this is
the last thing I'll say about it.
All in all, drama sucks.
And I hope it doesn't ruin the spotlight for the people, for
the team.
teams and the creators that are still um in the world cup uh
i i would love if people support the remaining teams in the
world cup because they deserve the spotlight and um and uh
and you know you know this is like their chance to shot and
it's a lot of money for them too um because they made it to
the final so now they get more money and i know like
currency conversion rate especially to like uh for like
south america uh and like asia is like um the for for
american us dollars too uh it's like a lot a lot of money
too in general so like they deserve it they worked really
really hard everybody who made it to the finals worked
really really hard to get there and they deserve all the
attention and spotlight um they get from this event and i
hope that even despite all the negativity people will still
see some pauses into it and i have no hard feelings to any
of my teammates i even sent a dm um i even sent a dm to warn
right after the tournament i don't think he read it because
i he was he was going through a lot and i like you know i
felt really bad and like nobody deserves to be like you know
piled up on uh like that like like like you know because
we're all people we're all human and i like i don't think
you saw my dm because like it DMs and I'm like that that
shit does not have good notifications I would say I would
say that shit is so poorly programmed I'm I will not be
surprised if he never read he never saw the notification
because we don't follow each other yeah because I could
because he private his Twitter account when I wanted to like
follow him and send him that DM but like um yeah Twitter DMs
aren't the worst I don't so I don't think it reached him um
because I couldn't contact him on discord but i have no hard
feelings for anybody on my team um and you know even like i
was just like you know emotions get to everybody and um i
felt really like you know the synergy just wasn't there and
that happens i thought we would i thought i thought we would
be like gg go next but we didn't go next
That, but we didn't go next, guys.
I will say this was, this is me and FanFan.
This is teaching.
This is, this is me and FanFan.
What happened?
What, what happened?
yes
all right all right let's go now we play arm oh wait my
food's here give me a sec let me eat my food and then we
okay and then we played armor core put this image up I
pretend like that's me right now that's me it was not chichi
go next it was chichi nori
I'm back sorry I have to get a fork too um because I didn't
give me a fork for my jellybee's pasta and chicken can't I
be mad at me look how cute I am please don't engagement babe
with me look how cute I am Don't use me as engagement bait,
guys.
Look, I'm so cute.
I'm so funnable.
Don't do it.
I'm wearing a cute hoodie.
They will use me as engagement bait.
Guys, you don't want to five drama look at me looking like
this wait though i should have told the whole story no then
people be like wow she's not taking it seriously i was like
what if i told the whole story like this or even what if i
just told the whole story like like talk about it like this
like then it's like a paparazzi where
i'm All right, let me, uh, but the narrator, but they did,
in fact, want to use hair for engagement.
They, Doki, you're, you're, they already clipped you.
You're already on Twitter.com.
You already clipped you out of context, Doki.
It's already up.
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Duly noted and ignored.
on the boat you're in the super chat thank you thank you all
right let me keep my dolly bees
is now mukbang stream i'm sorry i'm sorry for people who
don't like serps i'm okay i don't know if this is is this a
me thing or like because i saw it on shorts so i don't know
if it's true but like like is it in asian cultures like it's
okay Doki, the clip went viral.
No, Doki, get out of there.
The Twitter drama is outside the door.
Anyway.
Doki, the clip has hit 200k views.
Doki, it's on livestream fails right now, Doki.
It's too late.
Another clip has hit the livestream fails.
No.
like fuck vtubers why is she pretending why oh why is she
pretending to be an anime girl no it'll be like oh she looks
she's so cringe it's like it's too late no not the cold
retweets no toky boys crank let's join the party
Anyway, um, I don't know if this is an Asian thing or if
it's just me, but I saw a YouTube short about it.
But like, for, is it true that like, like in Asian culture,
it's like not rude to like, do like, to lip, like, like
that?
Like, to just eat with your mouth open?
That's, is that true?
Because like, I never was taught to like, not eat with your
mouth open and go and do like, like, like, lip smack and
stuff yeah and then i saw youtube short about it being like
the culture differences um yeah i like the culture
differences between like asia culture and and like uh asian
culture and white culture and it's like like like chirping
and also lip smacking and eating like with your mouth open
it's like fine
like i was like i'm yum yum yum yum yum yum yum and
i saw youtube short about it i'm not like mixing i was just
saying like there was a youtube short about it so i wasn't
sure if like uh in chinese that's rude okay then my parents
didn't teach me
but my parents didn't teach me and i'm sorry i'm sorry guys
i got engagement i am a of engagement baiting I am a victim
of engagement baiting I just I'm just a little guy to know
please don't also cancel me for eating with my mouth open I
know she will fall for the bait and well that sucks Anyway,
I'm not gonna, I'm, anyway, I'm yum, yum, yum, yum.
Too late.
Don't fall for the shorts.
All right, let me eat my food.
Okay, he knows I'm eating food.
Come on, get in here and watch me eat.
You're not getting any of this.
You can watch me eat, but he's not getting this, which I
think is worse for him.
But that's his choice.
It's too late.
I was born into this.
Alright.
You gotta change me.
You gotta change me for who I am, guys.
Alright.
Let me...
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Yoki doesn't feed her dog.
Oh, another clip has hit live stream fails.
But that one is true, though.
That one isn't out of context.
Look, see, he left because he knew I wasn't going to to give
him food he actually left he just walked away
oh my god who oh wait this is a funny tweet who on that
marvel rivals canada team needs some money for the
tournament aren't all these players big creators anyway
other than fanfan i don't know who that is i would say
fanfan is a bigger creator than me or i
like that's so funny it's like who the fuck is fan fan but
fan fan's a bigger creator than me though like
she like she like co-hosted the streamer awards like that's
guys i got no i got engagement baited i clicked on the tweet
too because oh my god i got engaged with beta they got me
they're like he got me
no don't get faded i was good i fell for the fate no no no
what no dad no no He just wants food.
That was a pity.
It was so funny though.
Like, I don't even know who that is.
I don't know who that is.
I'm sorry, it's just, I'm sorry.
Like, I'll give him a treat.
he won that one must be a troll he got me I fell for it that
one that one was that one's funny though that one was funny
I'm pretty sure fan fan in terms of like people who know her
like in terms of like people who know her like normies too
she had she would be like below xqc i'm pretty sure like in
terms of like who fan fan is because she literally she
literally co-hosted the streamer awards and she knows like
all the big streamers like within like who are like all the
top big streamers yeah she's a normie streamer like she
literally has um she has the most follow like i would say
like i am known um in terms of follower wise maybe i'm like
actually no i'm gonna check share for him uh like uh yeah
following wise it's like me but i'm still like pretty niche
within yeah i'm like pretty niche within like the vtuber
like community like i'm like in the vtuber community which
in itself is a niche community um but she's like everywhere
within like all the big big streamers like she's literally
everywhere and she's a collab with all the biggest streamers
um within the normie sphere like within the top like normie
twitch sphere like she's interacting with all the biggest
streamers out there like the so it was so funny so I feel
like she would be like the second most well-known streamer
within our team so it's so funny it's like are they're all
big streamers other than fan fan I don't know who that is
and I was just like I was like they got me they fucking got
me there
they baited me so hard with that one it like actually got
that was so fucking funny i always have niche i am in a more
niche community within na i'll say within na because vtubing
is not niche outside of na but within na there's still a lot
of like we can we there's still a lot of growth in the v2me
community in na
yeah it's a niche category in na
that's what i mean
no japanese normies no v2bers v2bers in japan have reached
the normie sphere for those who don't know v2bers are
everywhere in japan
yeah it's in the normie sphere in japan they have like for
those who don't know in japan they get vtubers to promote
movies yeah they like literally i remember seeing a clip
that they got like ryan ryan goslin
did a promotion with uh was it was a marina corone for the
that space movie project hail mary yeah She like they did
Ryan Gosland did a promotion with uh corona and marine for
uh project hell mary that's a big ass movie
yeah i was like what the fuck right y'all was like hello
corona and marine i was like what the fuck yeah yeah and
then corona and marine had uh dub roles in project hell mary
for those who don't know the students uh the voice ryan
gosselin students you get recognized corone by dude like i
would knew this because one of my friends is a big corone
fan and then he was like he and he also really really loves
project hell mary so then he was like try he's like look at
this clip they voiced this and then um and then like and
then i was like where's marine and he's like i don't know i
can't yeah i was like i can't hear marine and then he's like
i don't know either yeah we could we could hear corona but i
don't know where i don't know which one was marine i i i
didn't i couldn't recognize it
i just saw it that's crazy i don't know if someone could
tell me which voice was marine that would really help a lot
because like i think he like he was trying to he rewinded
like numerous times for like apparently like for like an
hour trying to figure which one was marine's voice that you
couldn't figure it out i was like i don't know i'm sorry i
don't know which one is there
um oh my god i'm still thinking about that tweet that's so
funny god that was a good engagement bait guys that was that
was a really good engagement bait i'm that was so
It's okay like it
They got me there They got me there Oh yeah Do I see the Do
you guys see the Um
Um The Ludwig drama That happened Oh since we're talking
about drama anyway No Since we're talking about drama Let's
just tackle it all today on the stream We will play the game
soon.
I just need to finish my food because this is my This is my
like first meal of the day actually I woke up at like three
so Those who didn't know there's like another drama I feel
like that might have I don't know it It was a lot of drama
and Basically for those who didn't know Tyler won and Ludwig
did a show match because like last last evo it was like lily
pichu and harada did a show match but this time they made um
they made tyler one and ludwig do a show match to see who's
the better player i think it was like out of 13 matches or
some shit
um yeah and tyler one streamed all his gameplay like you
know all his practices and rank stuff because he actually he
enjoys street fighter and thought first to 10 okay it was
first to 10 and um lugwig didn't stream any of that he only
did like one i think he did like very little streams um of
street fighter and then apparently during the actual day um
so like when the streams he did do he was playing jp so uh
so uh kaiwan all he did was grind again learn counters
against JP because he thought Ludwig was playing JP and then
during the tournament um Ludwig pulls out Marissa out of
nowhere like a Masters Marissa out of nowhere and people
were and then everyone was so confused they're like aren't
you a JP player and then Ludwig was like you thought I was a
JP player I pre those are pre-recorded games that my
recorded for me why I pretended to play and yeah so and then
he was like I learned all of and all my rate all my practice
off stream yeah yeah yeah and then I think I watched a
little bit Taiwan stream post by the way that's not the part
where everyone got pissed by the way um yeah and then so um
i watched a little bit of tyler one stream right after and
he was like that's just psych that's just psychopath he was
literally was like that's psychopathic man like why would
you just like that like you do you learn a character that
was my full counter behind the scenes and it pre-recorded a
fake character just to fuck with me that is fucking
psychopathic like that's what Tyler one was saying like
sociopathic even yeah and but that wasn't the drama the
drama was like like it's like you didn't even have to do
that that's just a twist in the night the
real drama the real like the yeah the real drama was that
Tyler love would beat Tyler 1's ass, 10-3.
And the whole show match was modern versus classic.
And Tyler 1 is a modern player.
Guy one modern player.
And Ludwig was a classic Marissa player.
so he 10-3'd Tyler 1.
And then they gave the mic to Ludwig and asked him, why
don't you stream Street Fighter?
Why didn't you stream your practices?
And then Ludwig was like, I like Street Fighter, but I like
viewer numbers more.
And he's like, I'm sorry, I just like viewer numbers.
And then that's the drama.
So everyone is now, everyone is now mad at Lugwick because
they're saying like, they're like, oh, oh, like that's so BM
at Evo.
Like, why would you say that in front of everybody in Evo?
And he was sponsored to do the show match, too.
To be fair, yeah, he is, like, really good at playing the
villain, too.
Yeah.
So, so, and then the engagement bait worked, guys.
Now everyone's talking about it.
Now, now everyone's talking about it.
The rage bait worked.
he rage baited at evil
yeah w engagement bait and he wait he did it he got that
everyone's just talking about that instead of love like 10-3
10-3ing to either one
I feel like he's always been He knows how to play the heal
very, very well.
It's like a known...
He's got no rage baiter.
He won't do something naturally to him.
Alright.
Let me finish.
I finished my pasta, but I still have a bit of chicken left,
so I'm gonna...
Take one more bite of chicken and we'll play the game.
Sorry, guys, for the food break.
For the food intermission before the game.
do hope you guys enjoy the little zatsu free game zatsu
a little mini mukbang i think that's everything that's all
it got oh yeah it's food gossip we're at lunch we have it's
lunchtime it's recess right now we're in the cafeteria i was
like guys did you hear the newest dish guys guys you hear
the newest gossip oh my god i heard tyler one broke up with
lovewick today you're like what they
broke up i was like yeah i heard it from i heard it from
jenny in the in the second row lockers they were talking
about it spill the tea girl i know apparently yeah
apparently they saw they saw tyler one they saw Tyler one oh
no they saw no I think it was they saw Ludwig was signed
last Saturday at the spring dance and then um and then but
then he told Tyler that like he couldn't he couldn't be his
date because he like he couldn't make it to the spring dance
because he was doing something with his dad last week no way
girl are you serious Yeah, I know.
And they were going to go to prom together.
Isn't that crazy?
It was written in the boys' upper restrooms.
She's writing fan fiction viral, viral.
This is our little gossip hours.
Oh my god, girl.
did you guys hear what jessica did last summer oh my god i
have to tell josh about this oh my god you should you text
him right now i heard like he's been into tyler for so long
like she's he's free now this might be his chance i'm so
what he came in was like am i gonna get food now and then he
saw i wasn't giving food and then was like please let me out
i forgot the gout i thought i forgot the whale picture was
still up
i don't even know if there's any other drama other than that
i think i got all the drama throughout the day it's like
welcome everyone dude what was the philip de franco um intro
that he used to do I remember watching Philip DeFranco a lot
like 10 plus years ago you guys remember Philip DeFranco
where he does like the news of the day and stuff where he
gives you updates on what happens every day so like back
then I used you know before I got my news from Twitter I
used to watch Philip DeFranco when he gives me the like the
news what's up you beautiful bastards yeah i watch no i
haven't watched i think like i only watched him when and um
i only watched him when he was at his peak when everyone
used to watch him i heard he won the mr beast competition
though
um and he wasn't even trying like he won a mr beast
competition okay i thought that was like really funny let's
just jump into it yeah Oh yeah, oh yeah, that's a what's up
you beautiful bastards.
Why let's just jump into it today Did you hear?
Anyway, so I remember he entered a mr.
Beast competition Where where it was like all the old school
youtubers All the old school youtubers he brought back all
the old school youtubers like you know Bill DeFranco was
there some of the alley jams I think Allie was, I don't
know.
I know, like all the old Minecraft streamers were there.
Oh, yeah, SourceFed.
Oh, I used to watch SourceFed a bit too.
And, oh, Ali A, sorry, Ali A, Vanas, like everybody.
Everyone was like, back in the old YouTube days, got
invited.
And then Fletcher Franco only went there to, like, just
wanted to see what the behind the scenes look like in the
Mr. Beast production.
And he got first place.
And the finals was literally building a Minecraft house.
He was against two other Minecrafters.
And he had to build a Minecraft house.
And it's like whoever built the best Minecraft house.
IRL.
It was like an IRL Minecraft house building.
They were given like these little cubes.
And they had to build a house.
And the remaining participants had to vote on which
Minecraft house which irl minecraft house was the best built
and like it was built the best and then like and then philip
the franco won against two other minecrafters which is crazy
like i was like bro that's your whole thing that's literally
your whole thing that was your career bro how do you
How do you lose to the newsman?
Not enough resources.
Oh,
wait.
I didn't watch the full clip.
I just watched the clip where they were voting.
Bro, Vanos helped himself.
Oh, boy.
He destroyed Alia's A house.
So he was like, 1v1.
No.
No more.
I'm done eating.
I'm going to put this away so he knows I'm done eating.
I didn't know that.
I didn't see that part of the clip.
I didn't realize he was drunk as hell.
He saw me finish eating, guys.
So should be fine.
Let me wash my hands and then we play.
I'll be back.
I'm back guys Meri, thank you, super chat, thank you, thank
you, Papa, thank you, super chat, thank you, thank you,
Anna, thank you, super chat, thank you, thank you, shame
about the tournament, Woes Doki, maybe you can redeem
yourself in a shadow armor core tournament, armor goons, eh?
Thank you, let's super chat, thank you, does that privacy?
Oh yeah,
I saw a Google Dockey pop up.
I'm in Oh, okay, never mind, this has Nothing to do with me.
This is VTuber drama.
I was like, oh my god.
People are making Google Docs again.
Oh, I was like, oh.
Unrelated.
Unrelated to the Rivals thing.
Don't keep, please.
Oh, save.
Why is your timeline full of drama?
I keep getting engagement, baby.
I can't help it they all they are always engagement baiting
me
you die it's my my algorithm yeah it's my number I click it
I can't help it I just I keep clicking it guys Someone stop
me.
I'm the target audience.
Why can't we be friends?
Like that's just me during that entire That entire
situation.
Why can't we be friends?
Just like I need to charge my really fast shake I need to
charge my mouse.
Okay.
Like, I should have charged my mouse during.
Ah!
No!
Okay.
It's okay.
I should have charged my mouse while I was eating.
But it's okay.
We can play with a little bit of a cable for a bit.
Just a little.
It's fine.
It's not like an actual shooter game.
So I can play.
play with the cable on and charge this all right let's let's
now play armored core
all right let me set everything up for it all right
let's see jack over there uh armored car there you go why
can't we be friends why can't we be friends why can't we be
friends why can't we be friends why can't we be friends why
can't we be friends
Time for big booms.
Big booms solve everything.
Oh yeah, I'm officially a raven now.
Oh yeah, it's supposed to be croaky.
But then I wanted to be like, you know.
I'd be like, can't be mad if I'm just a little guy.
True.
It must have saved.
right no don't make me fight her again don't make me fight
her again don't make me fight her again okay wait this
is her mission this is her this
is her mission are we good oh i'm good i'm good i'm good
okay I don't remember what the mission was.
I had to double check, guys.
I had to double check.
Okay, we're good.
We're good.
All right, guys.
It's time.
We are looking for sponsors so I can buy more Big Boom.
Guys, who would like to sponsor?
Goonbot.
Goonbot requests.
sponsors for more big boom.
Ad space is open.
Please request what you want on your ad space and also where
you would like to place it.
Skip ads.
Yeah, we're like a Formula One race car right now.
Can you grab five big Medis Medi fan club?
Where would you like your five big Medis?
Well, Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Would anyone want to open him for a sponsor slot?
Going once.
Going twice.
Sold to five big Medis.
All right.
Let's grab.
License clinker spanker.
Oh, I'm sorry, Quill.
JK.
I saw a bigger bid.
Gordon wins.
The sponsored.
Sponsored ad space.
Paid actor.
Thank you, Gordon, for the magenta.
Supa.
You can't outfit.
License clanker, spanker.
That's a lot of letters, so we're gonna do our best.
Why can't we be friends?
Why can we be friends?
Oh, fuck.
Okay, it's okay.
It's just the first letter.
That's fine.
License.
Thank God I have, like, the data, too.
Can we get healers need more kills on the side of the mech?
Oh, my God.
I'm sorry, Gordon.
You got outbid.
Thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you.
NSD.
Okay, luckily, I already have the L.
So, like, I just...
All right.
All right, there you go.
I have the L.
healers need more kills on the side of the all right it's
fine okay uh q wait see i'm trying to remember how to do
this okay that's fine because we have the l we have like
half the letters already
Okay, healers.
Okay, that looks like an N, actually.
I should get rid of that.
That looks like an N.
Delete that.
I'll grab another letter.
H.
Healers.
E.
all right a
then we have we have L done and then we get another E
luckily all of these are like repeats too so that's good you
know there's
I would like to purchase a vowel please I would be like
alright guys just purchase letters and we'll make a word out
of it each He's super chat, gets a letter.
Healers.
Certified Transformers Banger.
Okay, Gordon, thank you for the Akasufa.
Thank you.
I would like to guess, please.
All right, Gordon.
All right, do I have...
have any repeating letters certify, transformers, bang.
Okay, I don't have C.
All right, let's get C in here.
All right, C.
All right, we gotta move all these letters now.
Okay, we'll put all, okay, we have E.
All right, certify.
All right, thank you for this super chat.
I made a bill based on your model.
You can see it.
You can see it with the share codes.
Oh, shit.
I'll check it out.
I don't know.
I hope it doesn't over...
I don't know why it doesn't take my...
My goon, by the way.
I'll do it at the end.
Thank you.
Gambit.
GG's.
Gordon with the red out of nowhere from downtown.
Okay, I need a...
Certified.
Okay, I need an...
R.
Okay, we have the R here.
Okay, and then we get rid of...
Okay, where is the A?
The A here.
Now we're, like, piecing everything together.
And we get the L away.
Where the fuck is the L?
Not that L, this one.
Alright, now we just need the T.
Okay.
T.
Sur-tified.
Oh, my God.
This might be the longest one.
It's literally like, can I guess the word now?
Sur-tified.
Okay.
We have all the letters, I think.
Now we have all the letters.
And we just copied.
Certified.
We have almost all the letters.
Where the fuck is E?
I would like to solve!
Can I buy another letter?
Okay, E.
Oh.
Certified.
Transformer, banger.
T.
Okay, R.
The fuck is R.
There you go.
R.
Oh my A.
We have an N.
We do not have an N.
Okay.
S.
Oh.
Oh my god, please.
F Do we need O We're almost there, guys Okay Okay, now it's
all repeats I'm pretty sure Oh shit Or Medi made me Reset
Nah Do we have all the letters?
Alright, okay.
Alright.
Thank you for the Akyuta Supa.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, wait.
We have all the letters.
We have.
Okay, I just need an M.
I just need an M.
Alright, M.
K.
M.
Alright, thank you for the Akyuta Supa.
Thank you.
Where is this E?
Oh, there it is.
E.
I just need a D.
I just...
Wait, okay.
I need to get rid of all these other... Okay.
Alright.
Let's get a little funky now.
Serena, bye.
Okay, I have all the letters this time.
Thank you for the awesome, but Lord grosses.
Thank you.
Alright, that's fine.
That's fine.
We can reset all of this.
C.
Sort of.
Okay, C.
E.
Fuck.
Okay.
R.
Oh my god.
We actually have all the letters to stab.
This is good.
I don't have to get any letters.
I don't have to pick a letter anymore.
Alright.
Too many sponsors, only one ad space.
It's a bid war right now.
My lobster's too buttery.
And my pillow is always cold.
All right.
Where's the fuck is...
Where's the other tea?
All right, Toki.
I'm trying.
I can't find the tea.
wait oh there it is all right certified all right okay okay
we just need an h oh wait we have an h okay my core is too
armored there's so i can buy so many big booms what am i
gonna do with all these big booms now oh no
put all of this away.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh my god, where the fuck is F?
Oh, there's F.
Alright.
Where did I put the hag?
Where did I put it?
Okay.
H.
Where's A?
Oh, A?
Okay, I just need a G.
I literally just need a G
Alright, and we'll put all these letter at the bottom I need
to save this now There we go, we did it
This works It can't be bothered to delete it Inside, it's
fine It's closed, it's closed Many more clothes Many more
Many more has clothes It's We're sending to the printers job
done all right let's put it on decal where do you where do
we what's where do we put it anyway could be like on the
upper part of the arm like a tattoo right we're gonna put it
there it's like a little tattoo there
you go That should show up, right?
You can see it.
See, it's right there.
Guys, it's right there.
It's Camel!
Why you judge my Camel?
Alright, time to play.
Does she remember the controls?
Yeah, it's like mom tattoo.
It's a mom tattoo.
I have a personal request to ask you.
Yeah?
I want to go there and survey the area.
Even before the coral surge, that place had been all but
abandoned.
It's an old structure dating far back into the colonization
of Rubicon.
There must be items of interest from throughout the planet's
history there.
So much history.
As I'm sure you're aware, I have no resources with which to
pay you.
Oh, sorry, I can't do that then.
I can't propose an alternative.
Yeah?
If you find any wrecks left by the PCA, you should try
accessing them.
What does that give me?
And the Rubiconians are gathering data on PCA technology.
Whatever you collect, I can exchange for credits.
Oh!
The funds to you.
Alright.
Nothing said, girl You have a way to give me money I do job
Money equals job done I've taken a few liberties Walter
thinks you've gone on a geological survey Thank you for
doing this for me Nothing said, girl
Some As long as you have the money to pay me That's alright
Main system Activating combat mode Let's see, I can
remember.
I'm trying to remember.
How do I lock in again?
Lock on target?
It's a male mouse button, right?
Wee.
Guys, she says it's a simple job.
But I don't think it's a simple job, guys.
Guys.
It's never a simple job.
They always lie about that.
that oh oh shit i forgot i have a knife there you go okay
it's five all right nice access i'll exchange it for i
always forget there's a knife let me i think my mouse is
charged enough
Hello, everybody.
Anybody else here?
They'll be like, in and out.
Don't worry.
It's never.
Never just an easy in and out.
Whoa, whoa!
Do not fall.
Okay.
Sure.
Meow.
I'm here.
Oh, fuck, that's a knife.
Retraped by the knife yet again.
This data seems valuable too.
I'm so glad this is turning into a profitable mission.
A guy.
We're seeing or I'd be out of here.
I wouldn't even be here if there was no money involved.
Weeer.
So easy.
It's like there's no security.
Maybe a little too easy.
Nah, this can't be a trap.
Surely there are just easy missions during mid-game.
Surely, right?
Yeah, that's it.
This is my freebie.
It's a freebie mission, right?
It's a cozy early mission for a job well done.
I blind, I bind left hand to a thumb button on a mouse so I
don't hit accidentally trying to shoot.
Also right click quick boost.
Oh, that sounds smart.
Something I won't do.
Oh, there's one.
It's my me.
He's collecting the scraps in my mind.
my dead brethren for money.
Assistant number one has lost his mind.
His research has utterly consumed him.
Granted, there may be some logic to see pulse sensory
augmentation of human subjects, but no ethical scholar would
ever dare cross that point of no return.
Mankind is driven mad by possibilities.
What does Koro represent, if not sheer potential?
Come on, if you're a...
If you dad, you would want your homie to make money off your
body.
That created you.
But without it, we never would have made contact.
Think about it.
To help the homies out.
Life after death.
Is this not...
Where am I supposed to...
What the fuck?
Wait, what's that?
Alright, reset.
See something over there.
How do I get there?
Where's the hottie hole?
Oh, it's here.
What?
How do I fit in?
My mech's too big.
Where the fuck is the hole?
Is there a hole here?
Oh, there is a hole here.
Whee!
Did I do it?
Okay, I did it.
Data processed.
Yay, $16,000!
I can buy like two big booms from that.
Did I go this way?
I guess I should go back then?
No, no.
It's fine, sir.
It's...
It's, it was, guys.
It was not fine.
Guys, I had a feeling that it was not fine, guys.
Okay, wait.
There we go.
I make this.
Okay, maybe I should have done that earlier.
I got recharged.
My greatest enemy.
Gravity.
Who would have known?
All right, connecting.
yeah how long has it been since i first saw your foot or
voice fear not she said there was always be plenty she told
me this i was embedding rubicon's blessings one faithful day
if i were you i'd never allow this i reply i was forever
ashamed by my deceit wait are you cheating on me the
liberation front's ideological who is he talking to uh
appears to be something exceptionally who is he talking to
huh are you two-timing me wait a minute who is she you
who is she the fuck how you not how did he okay i was gonna
say how did he jump past that
who's the other clanker huh
Oh, there's a lot of them.
They're like little bugs.
I want to make sure there's nothing else around me.
I'll go this way.
Oh, yeah.
Her sister.
Yeah, your twin sister.
Hmm.
So convenient.
So convenient that your twin sister who looks just like you.
And sounds just like you.
Oh.
Yes, unironically.
Share.
Wink.
There's something down here.
There's a lot of people down here.
I'm going down anyway.
Just because I want to kill him.
Fuck these guys in general.
Okay.
I knew it.
I knew there was money.
There was no money.
That was not money.
Is that money?
No, that was not money.
I thought that was money.
I guess there is nothing here.
These are just enemies.
Well, I just killed some workers for no reason.
Wait, how do I get back?
Wait a minute.
There you go.
Where am I?
Oh!
stop stop stop all right i'm good
we're okay
oh whoops i thought that was an ending for a sec
yeah that'll buy me half a boom oh they're like next to each
other that's convenient
the call tide is rising at an abnormal rate this resonance
This is just some kind of mutation.
Run the calculation.
How much time do we have?
47 hours, 2 minutes, 16 seconds?
We still have time.
Deploy EBS.
According to the timestamp, this was recorded two days
before the fires of Ibis.
This seems to be about the warning signs of the calamity
right before it struck.
I'm not picking up any more data stores.
Did I do it?
Yeah, I did it!
about Rubicon's past or the nature of coral, then it was all
worth it.
Yay!
Wait, this was easy.
They did give me a free B.C., guys!
I knew it.
I'll never doubt my wife again.
Look at that.
I knew my wife who didn't cheat on me.
We got ourselves a deal, Handler Walter.
Michigan.
so Archibus met us halfway I gave them the heavy warship
fleet in exchange Balaam's in charge of putting down the
beast they also offered some top it was an in-and-out
mission quick one quick five minutes for once I'll provide
what support I can to yeah you're mad scientists RAD or
whatever and that hound of yours Michigan don't
underestimate Nothing went wrong.
I might have shot some unarmed workers, but like...
They knew what they signed up for.
Like, they signed the Weaver.
What kept you 6-2-1?
You're a famous mercenary now.
Oh my god, I'm pissed.
Oh my god.
That's on my autograph.
Oh my god, guys.
Alright, who wants to be my groupie?
Alright, nice.
I'm ready.
Destroy the...
Oh, it's time.
It's time to destroy the worm.
Don't worry, I won't forget about the little people, guys.
all right let's try the ice worm uh i'm at oh oh wait i need
to equip it what do i need to equip oh yeah the special
weapon that they gave me all right which one is was it
assembly it was it for my arm which
one was it yeah the needle launcher okay That should be for
my other arm.
Oh, there you go.
The anti-ice worm weapon design.
I forgot about that.
That was from last playthrough.
Equip dual needle launcher.
But then...
Oh, because it's anti-neutralized coal shielding.
Electric by fire massive.
To create a powerful discharge.
Wait, can I dual wield it?
No, I can only one wield it.
Is that the biggest boom?
Oh.
The biggest boom.
Wait, do I...
No.
You mean...
Big boom?
You mean I can have...
Two big booms?
Guys,
guys, no, guys, stop.
I can't get more happy than this.
Guys, guys.
I'm already close.
Two big booms.
Let's see.
Keep it on.
All right, let's see.
That's the dokey I know.
Where's my other big boom?
I promised two big booms.
There's no way.
There's no way I was lied to.
I can't get the second one.
I can't believe you guys bait me like this.
I gotta get your baited again.
up god this is how i always get engagement baited
i destroy the ice worm all right that should be fun
fell for it again all right i want you to attend first some
background before we go into detail The intercorporate
ceasefire is now in effect and we will be carrying out
coordinated attacks against the PCA.
The targets are the enemy occupied bases, the heavy warship
fleet, and the recently activated...
I'll cut to the chase!
That is a TLDR!
...against the PCA in theaters across Rubicon.
And you all got the short end of the stick.
You're here to take on the worst of our dirty work, hunting
the beast of the ice field.
Sure thing, Chief.
Tell you what?
I'll watch and let you know how badly that goes for us.
Gun 5, you just volunteered yourself for the front line.
Yay!
That's good, right?
Am I already gonna help me?
They're gonna help me too, right?
This is a joint mission.
Which means there's joint members.
Archibus will provide the means to break the first layer.
Okay.
That's me.
and it will deliver results.
Don't worry, I won't miss.
RAD's cooked up just the thing.
A neat little toy we call the Overt Rail Cannon.
I don't have that.
If we divert the spaceport standby power to the ORC, should
it hard enough?
Oh, they're gonna do that for me.
You can leave that to me.
I know a thing or two about sharpshooting.
Okay.
I'll oversee operations on the ground.
A ragtack who like this needs...
Yes!
Snail's gonna help me!
We could use some more suppressive fire.
Yes!
Send her to!
We're a team!
That's me.
That's me!
I volunteer!
I volunteer to go poke that beast with a stick.
Gun 13.
You get all
that...
Oh wait, Snail's the asshole.
He's so snobbed yet.
He was a stuck-up bitch from...
earlier.
All right, let's go ahead.
I got my stun, Nina.
All right, I'm ready.
It's okay.
Surely it can't be that hard to aim the big boom.
It's just a bigger boom.
Yeah, he was the stuck-up bitch.
Not even.
Stuck-up bitch.
But the gang's all here!
And Snail.
Can't be that hard.
It's just a bigger boom.
of experiences with booms on
me god i look beautiful look at me go
all right guys which do you which guys which one do you
think is my big boom
which one is it guys
Holy shit!
Okay, wait a minute.
Oh, wrong one!
JK, that was...
Even though I knew that was...
Alright.
Oh, no.
Wait.
Wait, no one's...
Oh, there's a charge up.
Wait a minute.
Enjoy the show.
And don't forget to smile.
Oh, don't forget to smile.
What do you mean?
There's a charge up.
Wait, wait.
Yeah!
Let's go!
Shoot it!
Oh, shit, but not me.
connecting eml modules opening energy turbines output at 80
percent it's fine we're doing good sighting correction a
okay 90 95
i won't miss
go go 13 the head's open for a direct hit which
She won't miss.
God, I'm sorry.
I was like, I did it.
He's down.
I forgot the main mission.
I already forgot the main mission.
I even hit it first try.
The pie won't miss, but she will.
What?
Okay, that was a drive-by.
Boom!
What?
Oh, I missed.
That was...
Whoops.
Okay.
Oh, my god.
Wait, this is fucked up.
This is actually...
This is fucked up!
I'm launching.
I right-clicked instead.
I used them.
wrong boom I use the wrong boom okay okay I get it now guys
I get it I actually quite a first tried it and then I got a
little confused I got a little confused guys I used the
wrong boom and I got boom all right I downloaded I
downloaded the worm the worm has been downloaded guys worm
has been download oh oh oh I know where my buttons are for
real this is v4 rusty Rail cannon is good to go.
Don't die before I get a chance to fight.
Come to me.
Tourist.
Got a message from the chief for you.
Where is he?
Um, there we go.
I told you.
I told you I downloaded.
Nobody believed me.
Okay, I won't miss.
I won't miss.
Guys, guys, I won't miss, guys.
a okay 90 95
i won't miss boom
i won't miss
yes i told you guys i told you i won't miss i won't miss
yes i told you that's my goat this is just the first hurdle
it's just the first heard of.
Okay.
Look, I'm not you!
I don't care about you!
I won't miss.
I missed.
And I missed.
And I missed again.
And I shot.
And I missed.
Where is he?
Boom!
There we go.
Rusty!
Rusty, it's your turn!
I will miss.
I just missed.
And I know it pops again.
And I missed again.
Watch out for friendly fire.
What?
Oh!
Boom!
Triple boom!
Okay.
Wait, something's wrong.
What's wrong?
We've underestimated this beast.
Wait, retreat?
Looks like things just took a nasty turn.
What do you mean?
He's so low!
Maximum output.
We can't afford to lose control of the situation.
This next shot will be my last.
Whoa!
Boom!
Okay, I dodged it.
Get dodged.
Taking significant damage.
Might be checking out soon too soon.
Okay, so I can't be close when he does that, when he does
the little red thing.
Wait, why did he leave?
Wait, it's just me and Chatty!
Chatty, no!
No, it's okay!
Chatty's still here!
Me and me!
Oh my god.
I need him to, like, get...
Good luck.
Boom!
Oh, we need to double hit that.
Oh!
No, it's just me?
How did you die?
How is it just me against the world?
It's literally me against the world.
all alone now all my friends are dead oh my god there they
are i literally see their fucking dead body there we go
rusty this is it don't miss rusty all eml modules connected
energy turbines at full capacity me and rusty me and you
let's end this together
Oh god, there's...
Please don't friendly fire me.
I don't know where the worm is.
Oh, shit!
Oh, please imagine if that hit me.
Like...
The target's core shield has been wiped out.
Absolute cinema.
Get clear, it's gonna blow!
Oh, shit.
oh it's gonna blow let me fucking dive in there I almost I
almost again dive into the bigger boom I'm like a moth to
the boom yeah it was like is that a bigger boom I gotta get
closer Like, yeah.
Coral voices.
Lost again.
I'm off to the boom.
I did it.
I'm a hero.
There's something I have to tell you.
What is it?
The Coral.
Yeah?
It's my family.
My brothers and sisters.
You're not close to them, right?
You're the Coral?
I believe.
from the coral tide.
I'm a Baconian without a body.
No one even knew I was there for such a long time.
Raven, you're the only one who...
Okay, we can repopulate.
You and me.
Go get your rest, 621.
Things are going to get busy.
The coral is made of wifus!
The coral is people.
I mean, she's a strange, right?
Oh my god, that's a lot of money.
That has to be the least booms I've ever used.
You can fascinate a doki with a piece of boom.
Pop-puss, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank
you.
It's like salmon, you know?
I guess I didn't say that.
Yes, it's like...
You know?
We do it like we do it.
Like the Sabbath.
Wait, it doesn't have a bot.
No problem.
You know?
The temporary alliance between the Archibus and Baylam
groups turned the tide of war.
We're winning the war and we're on the good side because
we're winning.
Only winners write history.
Though it was the Ice Worm mission led by Balaam that dealt
the decisive blow, Archibus, through their own engagements
with the PCA, augmented their strength with seized weaponry.
I'm technically a mercenary, so we don't have a side.
I'm like Switzerland.
Scales tipped in Archibus' favor.
And the Rubicon Liberation Front's hopes of fighting an
exhausted foe We're dashed
With the loss of their common enemy The rival factions War
for the...
Oh yeah, we built back the Civil War Whoops Oops Hey, you
know who makes...
Who comes up the victor In wars?
Me That means more money Wait, that's good for me More money
Yay 621 entering standard mode all right two new messages
who in america usa usa
remember more money equals more big homes no matter no
doesn't matter where i'm getting the money getting to where
the corals gathering do you remember the survey you carried
out asylum analyzed the data and learned about a massive
facility under the central ice field watchpoint alpha turns
out that the ice worm was defending the entrance to that
place okay it's time to let ourselves in oh
there's something you need to know yeah wave that friend
walter mentioned the comms database has no record of the
conversation he just told you about
What is it about?
He's after something more.
And he's using you to do it.
Me?
Okay, but how much am I getting paid, though?
Alright.
Registration number RB23.
Call sign.
Raven.
Your records have been updated.
A-rank virtual encounters are now available in the arena.
May these encounters further guide your technique.
Oh, I have more tutorial?
No.
Now?
It's chapter three.
Oh, no, it's arena.
Okay, they added arena.
Nice.
All right.
I was going to say, how do I have more tutorials, but it's
just arena, guys?
All right, next.
Nile.
Oh, we're almost at the end.
All right.
Nile.
Deputy commander of the Red Guns, the Balaam Group AC squad,
formerly the commander of the Baylam Security Force, a
preliminary police organization that preceded the Formation
of the red guns now distinguish himself an exceptionally
high arrest rate in those days the only man He never managed
to put in handcuffs was michigan then the commander of the
furlong armed fleet having failed to arrest the man He
instead set out for a friendly drink with his old nemesis.
Oh, it's the popo to kill him Oh, I'm rank a I told you guys
I told you I'm good Acceptable they give a super chat.
Thank you.
I bring a certain mr.
Krabs mindset to Rubicon of the PCA don't real appreciate
average armor core pets.
They're just like, Morals though, Doki.
Morals.
All right, but does Moral pay for more big booms?
I don't think so.
Morals doesn't pay for booms.
Where did he go?
Oh shit, he's fast.
Oh shit, but I'm faster.
Guys, I might not be faster.
Wait, how do I do the...
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he's so fast.
Oh, that's a miss.
Oh, that's another miss.
What do you mean, you have two, bitch?
Oh, my God.
That's fucking right.
Hoor!
Don't give her a try to start the second summer of love with
our...
Thank you for the Super Chat Airborne.
Thank you, thank you.
It's salmon season, guys.
Me and my wife.
Heading up river.
Yay!
More money!
Oh, that guy was easy.
Got him.
All right, what's next?
Oh, shit.
Yeah, fuck this guy.
Deputy Commander of the Vesper.
The Equibus groups augmented in human squad.
After receiving Generation 8's augmentation surgery, Snail
continued to receive follow-up treatments.
as new technologies enter the mainstream so as to make their
merits his own.
Many augmented humans have died in order to assure the
safety of his repeated agenda.
Jesus Christ, he's like roided up.
That guy is just all steroids and plastic surgery.
What even is like real anymore for him?
He's like that billionaire that has his son, that does blood
transfusions with his son.
Arena combat aptitude evaluation program Number six, rank A.
Only rank, your only rank six after all that surgery?
That's sad.
He looks maxing right now.
He's trying to bog.
Main system.
Activating combat mode.
Where is he?
Is he above me?
What the fuck?
he's over here.
I was like, where the fuck is this guy?
Whoops.
Get over here.
You bitch!
Sorry.
That fucker.
Boom!
That's right.
That's fucking right.
Surgery ain't gonna do shit.
Look at that.
Look like a beta son of a bitch.
Boom.
Get out of here.
Get your ass out of here.
I put that mega in place.
Exactly.
I'm the alpha here.
An independent mercenary who arrived on Rubicon around the
time that a coral response was rediscovered, held to be a
member of Branch, a hacktivist collective active in the
Rubicon system.
Chartreuse is said to have dealt a critical blow to the
closure system during the plot to Tax Station 31.
Branch is made out of a rotating group of four plate people,
and Chartreuse is believed to be the second oldest of the
current roster.
All right, let's just start.
five that bad I literally steam walked the rank six guy I've
steam rolled him my steam walked it's like just very slowly
walk you over him oh wait his emblems cool as hell bro that
guy had his shading what the fuck he shaded his emblems we
try hard
Yeah, but my tank is better.
Wait, why is he...
Why is he flying?
Oh, shit!
Told you my tank is better.
Oh, my God, you fucker!
Wait, wait, his tank is better!
His tank might be better!
Me too!
No!
Oh my god!
Wait!
Why is this tank so strong?
Come on guys!
That's not fair.
Like her tank kid, kid, my god.
There's no way!
Can't help boom the big boom!
The boom, Meister!
Oh my god!
His boom!
They're so big.
That fucking cheater.
That cheater.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Please, please, please, please, please, please.
No!
I should have stayed on the ground.
I got so greedy.
Oh my god.
I was like, I just need one hit I just need one hit that's
all I need me versus a tick she tells you not to worry about
it's fine I
can know what to do no I still know what to do though.
I'll do mine's first two.
God, her bones are so big!
Okay.
Yes!
The combo!
I knew it.
I told you, yes!
I told you!
I am the bigger boom.
Just don't get hit, guys.
No hit.
No hit, run.
right there yeah I didn't get hit at all all all right last
one last one in the arena thumb her name is thumb father the
Rubicon Liberation Front veteran military commander and
founder the school of quarrel mysticism as a young man
though a man was once a dozer bargain under the fires of
Ebis burned the star system.
In the fire's aftermath, he developed an ardent belief in
the symbiosis with the Coral.
This belief informed the finally deals of the Rubicon
Liberation Front.
Ideas that made matters of the countless Coral Warriors.
Alright.
Last guy.
Can't believe they named this kid Thumb.
They really fucking hated this man.
He didn't want a son for some shit.
He must have been an accident, kid.
Subject AC, Astreak, call sign, Thumb Dolmayen.
Commencing evaluation.
Alright, here we go.
Oh my god.
You don't matter.
They didn't even give you a real map for your simulation.
Oh my god, wait, he's fast.
Wait a minute.
No, wait a minute.
Wait.
He's so fast.
Oh.
fuck not fast enough that's fucking right where do you go oh
wait he was so eat that's why you're retired old man boom
that's fucking right this concludes a rank evaluation that's
rank four bro go back to your retirement home bro
stay back in the home that's why i didn't give you a app
nice steamrolled yeah cat outrun me you can never outrun a
tank he's definitely washed
oh it's a title oh i was gonna say who names your kid dumb
it's like when you name your kid disney all mind exists for
all mercenaries
you all right let's spy explosive I will get more melee and
then we'll grab explosive too all right that's good max it
out all right let me get water real quick and then we'll do
the next mission mission whichever one it is I'll be back
guys all
right I'm back Zechra Papa Jay Neppers on uh solid alan
thank you the super chat thank you thank you thank you
airport thank you the super chat thank you thank you this
bird plays like a gorilla that's good you don't want to
fight a gorilla winston you'll fight winston overwatch
here's the charm 621 to that underground facility watch
point alpha i managed to talk archibus into letting us lead
their They jumped at the chance to use an independent
mercenary as their canary.
Balaam has already barged in, taking several red guns and MT
squads.
Seems they want to be ready for a run-in with Archibus' new
firepower.
You'll start by descending through Depth 1, a vertical
chamber sector.
distance from autonomous defenses left by the PCA.
Oh yeah, I meant like Disney as in like, some people named
their kids first named Disney after Disney.
Even though Disney is the last name.
That's what I mean.
I've seen like some people, there was a YouTube short, but
like which one was named by the girl, which one is named by
the wife, and which one was named by the dad.
And then one of the kids name was Disney.
And I was like, why would you do that to that kid?
Like, why would like why would you ever why would you do
that to the kid bro she's gonna get bullied man she's gonna
ultra think of that disney smith imagine being disney smith
ultra think of the super chat thank you thank you i bet five
dollars she won't make it for a try prove me wrong joki oh
shit okay i'll do anything for five dollars
We're gonna meet your family Oh my gosh our relationship
guys Our relationship is going to the next level
Don't quote me on that I'd kill anything for five dollars
That's what we mean We're meeting our parents We're taking
our relationship to the next level You'll
be going down deep And there's no guarantee you'll come back
Oh shit We're gonna move in with your Whoa whoa maybe this
is a little too fast Girl you want me to move in With your
parents already
Me?
Main system Activating combat mode Commence mission Okay.
Whoops.
Sorry, it took up me a while to rev up.
Down I go.
I'm special.
Oh shit, wait a minute.
Made a minute.
Oh,
I have to jump?
Oh, that's fine.
Wee.
Below me?
Oh, shit!
Oh, my god!
Guys, below me.
Below me, guys.
ap at ap oh my guys i didn't first try it guys i didn't i
didn't
guys i might not have i might not have first tried it main
system activating combat mode like five dollars
No, my five, that's my five dollars, double or nothing,
double or nothing.
Ultra, double or nothing, guys.
Come on, double or nothing.
Double or nothing.
Let's go, Raven.
Oh, my God.
Maybe Big Boom is not the correct.
Maybe it's not the correct.
I will stab you.
Oh, God.
Why don't we double or nothing, bro?
Come on, bro.
Double or nothing.
Oh, God.
Triple or nothing, bro.
Triple or nothing, bro!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
All right.
Two repair kits remaining.
Oh, God, where's the next one?
Oh, God.
Get me in here.
I'm picking up enemy signals nearby.
Containing intruder, commencing termination.
Bombing and weaving!
I see him.
Oh, do you think they saw me?
No, right?
Do you think...
Guys, do you think you saw me?
I don't think they know.
Ow.
Do I get them from here?
You got closer!
Alright,
sorry.
They didn't see me.
There we go.
Whoops.
Oh my god, he only got hit like like he got poked like twice
All right, I'll chill here Should be fine
Yeah We are
Easy Yeah.
First tried it.
No big deal.
What's this?
Oh, it's item.
What did I get?
Ooh.
FBramara.
Okay.
Got to bob and weave again.
Where are the...
rays coming from plasma missiles plasma missiles
plasma missiles okay
all right all right just a few missiles no big deal
No, big deal!
Just a little wounded, just the graze.
Yeah, just one dash.
Oh my god, it should have been two dashes.
Never mind.
Where the fuck do I go after?
What the fuck?
Where's my next destination?
Oh, don't tell me it's all the way over there
Guys I think it's all the way over there Yeah, wait
Weir Weir Where, weir Weir, weir Weir Oh Whoa whoa whoa whoa
Oh my god, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no
Oh, yeah, no!
Shit!
I don't have heals anymore.
How much more do I have left?
Oh, God.
I'm going to see if I can...
Wait.
Oh, my God.
I'm not close enough.
I'm not close enough!
Why is it close?
Oh.
Wait, needle it?
Did I hit him?
I didn't even hit him.
I didn't even fucking hit this guy.
Oh my god.
I'm not risking it.
Oh my
god.
There's so much more left.
I fucked up.
Closer.
AP at 30%.
Uh-oh.
I swear to God, that was the fucking sniper.
I swear to God.
We were so close.
Oh, I should have used my shields.
Triple or nothing.
Triple or nothing, bro.
It's changed its combat routine, Raven.
Watch out for those plasma missiles.
Triple or nothing, bro.
Triple or nothing.
Oh, God.
Alright.
It's fine.
real okay right here I'm safe right here I was not safe I
was not safe I was not safe I'm dropping down oh my god oh
my god fucked up quad triple or nothing quad Drupal it got
bro from quad quad or nothing quad or nothing quad
Quad or nothing bro, bro quad or nothing
Okay, I get this for free Watch out for those plasma
missiles.
Okay, I knew I got oh my god, I made it
Okay, nice All right I just asked for There we go.
We made it.
I got a little greedy there.
I risked it for the biscuit.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
It's fine.
I make this.
Boom!
No, it's not.
We're fine here.
Oh shit!
Ah shit!
I didn't notice.
Okay, okay, hooray.
Thank you for the super chat.
I actually pressed shield instead of heal.
That was on me.
I pressed I was I don't know why I pressed you
I got so greedy I was so greedy Quinn tuple or nothing bro
quit quit tuple or nothing
Watch this this is it this is it
Quinn tuple or nothing bro
Yeah That free fall exactly have to be fun.
Oh, that's it.
There you go.
All right.
We made it.
Okay.
All right.
I made it to the next level.
We made it to the next level.
All or nothing, bro.
All or nothing.
You've got it in your sights now, 6-2-1.
Just need to get a little closer.
Where the fuck do I go here?
You gotta wait.
I'm all in, bro!
I'm all in!
After that, that has been the solution.
There we go.
All right.
It's the next stop.
Oh, I fucked up.
I might have been a little too overconfident.
Oh.
There you go.
You're up close now.
6-2-1.
Destroy the target.
Raven, it'll be easier to immobilize if you aim for the next
one.
Oh!
No!
Oh my gosh.
I'll hide here for now.
Yeah.
Did I hit it?
Is it... I can't tell!
What am I supposed to hit?
Oh, God.
I'll get the missile out of the way first, and then...
I'm going...
Ah!
what am i what am i supposed to hit what the oh that okay
that's what he meant by neck joy that's what he meant that's
what he meant by neck joy i was like where the fuck's the
neck that's a machine all right
Alright, we did it.
Guys.
I all are pay up.
All are nothing.
I told you.
Ultra.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
My stream cut up for the last seven.
So first try, right?
Right?
That's right.
All are nothing.
Pay up.
It's right!
It's repo man time!
The 31st time's the charm!
No new messages!
I just did a cool mission!
What do you mean no new messages?
I did so much!
Alright, underground exploration.
You're unacceptable.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you!
it take the dragon why does it cost dragons more money the
longer it takes you it's like a mean and
great all right here we go continue infiltration of the
subterranean facility and reach the deepest point all right
nice oh more rewards i like that the more people i kill here
comes the follow-up six two one you're going to be exploring
depth two The sector's made up of a sprawling rail network
designed to transport resources.
It'll be a complex route, with a lot of blind spots.
Be ready for close quarters combat.
Raven, there's something you should know.
I've obtained the cons log from the Balan squad that went in
before you.
It looks like they have another mission here, and it's not
part of their survey.
Guard mechs won't be the only threat.
Balaam's agenda is just as dangerous.
Alright, here we go.
Continual infiltration of the subterranean facility and
reach the deepest point.
Extra reward based on number of enemies destroyed.
Yay!
Alright, here we go.
Let's see.
You go in.
just so you know 61 my radar won't be able to reach the
lower depths oh no i lost a voice in my head i'm gonna lose
another voice in my head oh no what am i gonna do how can i
follow someone when there's no one to follow
main system activating combat mode let's go raven this is
where the survey begins and honest.
Alright, here we go.
To here?
It's camo!
I'm camouflage, guys!
The enemies can't see me and then I have flames on my gun,
so it'll shoot faster.
It gives me more frames per second.
Alright.
Anyone here?
Oh, there were people there.
All right.
Anyone else here?
Oh, what was the plan?
Like, go ambush!
Let me ambush into the knife!
Yeah, I can't be bothered with you doing those dodges.
I'm just gonna knife you.
According to the structural drawings, the route continues
past this partition.
Looks like the power's out.
way to bring it back online.
All right.
How do I bring back?
Oh, this way.
That has to be this way, right?
Down here?
An ambush.
Oh, yeah?
What are you ambushing for, huh?
Oh, my gosh.
There you go.
Can't be a traitor if I have no sides.
Which side am I betraying?
I'm not part of anyone's side.
It's this way.
Control panel identified.
This should get the power back.
Nice.
Oh.
Oh, someone said body.
A sketch by STV, a mask battlefield artist set by Psalm 21.
Last artist, the deadliest career to the art of hand-drawn
portraits.
Oh, yeah, AI took over after that, right?
They took their jobs!
High value among collectors in the know.
See?
This is what happens.
Guys, poor, the AI took the poor on his jobs.
Yeah, what part of independent mercies do they not
understand?
Oh yeah, see, this is what's gonna happen, guys.
The AI slot.
The heat exchanger sections up ahead.
This is a land where the comms lock for Valence Advanced
Squad cuts off.
like I understand what do you mean last artists do artists
just people just not have hands anymore like for you
freelancer oh shit where is he oh that's not good this is
not good guys this is not good I'm sick and tired of this
pit it'll all be over once you're sore yes to dead
are you really really really really okay that's not good for
me oh my god he's he's using cover he's cheating oh my
fucking guy no no no no no
I am.
Oh, shit.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Oh, my God.
I thought he would walk into.
Honestly, I was trying to get him though.
So he's one hit.
He's actually one hit.
Get out of here!
This isn't over.
It's time.
I swear.
Yeah, as if there's gonna be a next time, nerd.
That's fucking right.
Using cover like a fucking pussy.
Fight me like a man.
Bro.
One on one.
Brawl it out like men.
And I get fucking dunked on.
Being using cover like a goddamn pussy.
Yeah, we put the fries in the bag.
Here.
Get out of here.
Garbage.
Fucking garbage, bro.
Go back to school, little bro.
He goes, and it will return an Avengers Doomsday.
What the fuck hit me?
Oh, that.
What was that?
Yeah.
Is he coming back?
Oh, Oh my god, not again.
Alright, please find that data soon.
What do I do?
Why?
Why are you using it?
Look at this!
Oh god.
The pussy!
Oh, you're gonna run away, little bitches!
Yeah, you're sniping, run away!
Oh, just because I got closer.
Okay,
we're going to hack the systems again.
Has to be here.
There you go.
The only place left.
Yeah, running away like a coward.
Oh, it's loot.
Wait, that wasn't...
Where the fuck?
What the fuck is it then?
Where's the system I'm supposed to hack?
Guys, I'm a little lost.
Ventilation duck?
What the fuck is a ventilation duck?
Oh, over here.
Where the ventilation smoke is coming from.
No, that's just a fire.
Actually, I don't know.
for the sake of it.
Because I get money.
No?
I'm glad they don't have a yellow paint.
Where's my yellow paint?
I don't see no holes.
Oh, look down.
I don't want to die.
Oh, I see it.
Oh, there's more smoke.
Oh, they're already dead.
Wait, is he dead?
There you go.
Does my sword take ammo?
Because I don't know.
Look at these little guys.
Look at these money.
No?
Look at all that money.
Come on, little guys.
guys fight back!
Little guys fight back!
Guys, who would have known?
Who would have known the little guys can fight back?
They're like the little drones in StarCraft.
When they start, like the little the little drone workers in
the Zergs.
Those little guys.
There you go.
What is this the little area?
And more down?
There is more down.
There's no more down.
The hardest fight in this game.
I thought this was the down part.
What the fuck is the air duck?
Guys, I'm lost.
I don't know where my yellow pain is.
There is more down?
there was no more down there was no more down there was no
more down there was no more down
i'm up i'm blind i'm actually blind
guys guys i think i'm gonna die oh oh no oh no no
I don't know where the down is anymore.
Wrong down.
Where is more down?
Go down the other side.
Down into the right here?
Okay.
Oh.
There was more down.
There was more down!
Wait, no, I've been here.
Wait, no.
I've just...
I've been here.
There's more down!
Okay.
Found it.
Looks like it's connected to the control room.
Two repair kits remaining.
There was...
What the fuck?
Oh my god, like, where did it come from?
That's, that's what's scary
It's like little cockroaches that just drop Oh my god,
please Please There we go Yeah
Where are you too
Not up here
Wait, I scanned Oh, it's just these guys Here Here
This is a little confusing.
Not gonna lie.
Is that?
Oh, it's up here.
Oh, I see it.
There you go.
I'm here.
Oh, shit.
Hello, guys.
Hello, little guys.
Don't mind me.
Alright.
Oh, my God.
There's so many of you guys.
Oh, fuck it.
This is too many.
I'm just going to shoot that here.
I'm going to grab the loot.
Nice.
Oh, there it is.
I don't know if there's anything else.
There's enemies over there.
They're very unaware.
We're in the control room.
Now it's finding access point.
Oh.
Whoops.
Do you think they're still in the way?
Okay, that's good.
Nice.
Oh, he's still alive.
Oh, that's not.
Oh, there you go.
Oh.
Let's get rid of these guys real fast.
Just in case.
I don't trust it.
There you go.
I thought they were gonna...
Actually heal?
I actually pressed heal!
No!
I was trying to press V and I pressed heal.
Wait, was there a loot here?
What do you mean?
I don't see nothing.
I don't see no loot.
Oh, you mean this?
No, that's the Axis.
No, I did get the loot.
Alright.
That's good.
Is it just above?
I was scatting again.
I thought I got it.
There's no loot.
I got everything.
What is this box?
Did not get it?
yeah see
guys I did grab it you guys can't gaslight me huh I knew it
shake my head that's right get one dokeyed
hello oh resupply nice
fully resupply now all right it's time to fight a boss be
careful raven all right here we go this looks like a very
boss like oh this is a sniper bro bro this is this that's a
sniper bro isn't it that's him isn't it the fucking little
bitch ass
oh shit
transformers more than meets the eye Oh no, he's gonna snipe
me isn't he bro's got a whole fucking cutscene
Bro's got a fucking 20 second long cutscene oh Shit Naughty
the AI is taking our jobs At
30% Oh my god.
Oh god.
Fuck it.
I think by the time...
It's worth it.
It's fucking worth it!
Oh god.
Come on, I just need one hit.
I just need one hit.
There you go.
Boom!
Holy shit, this guy is so fucking stinky though.
Oh my god!
This guy is so tanky.
But I'm tank- What?
What?
Oh my god.
Is this worth it?
There we go!
I'm tankier.
Get out of here!
That's right!
You might be bigger, but I spent $3 million on my setup.
Money over skill.
Pay to win.
Let's go.
I will buy this battle pass.
Very nice.
All right, it's not too bad.
Not too bad.
Still made a lot of money.
Let's go.
You are the reason why GTA 6 is so expensive.
Do you guys hear that online one might be DLC?
You can't even play online multiplayer, apparently.
It's not included in the main price.
No new messages.
Why is no one talking to me?
Oh, it's because I'm in the pit.
I forgot.
It can't reach me.
Am I still underground?
Depth three.
Destroy the core of the...
Subterra.
Oh, yeah, I should feed dad.
I'll be right back, guys.
I'll feed dad and use the bathroom.
I'll be right back
Guys how much more do I have the do I have of the game left
guys?
Just want to know
A lot oh Okay, all right That's good to know I have a lot
All right
Let's see.
Alright, let's go.
Next mission.
I think...
How much more of this cave mission do I have?
621.
Depth 3 is next.
And it's where our intel gets sparse.
It's an underground cave.
Blocked at the end.
Two more?
Alright, we'll finish all the cave missions.
as long as it's in operation no one's getting any deeper
inside all right and then we'll call it here my voice is
dying as you guys can tell the laser is powered by a massive
reactor i want you to destroy it from the inside once the
barrier's down we'll step into the unknown okay
we're gonna meet the parents yay that's a good thing Destroy
the core of the subterranean facility reactor and disable
the laser barrier.
Alright.
Ooh.
Extra money.
I like extra money.
How does he know?
Yeah.
Wait a minute.
Is he your ex?
Huh?
There's something I have to worry about?
Coral?
How does he know?
Has he also...
Has he...
met your parents before me?
Summon's down here.
There's a door here.
Never mind.
Came from there.
There's a door here.
What's the wrong side?
Oh, they're just chilling.
I was like, yay, more for me.
all right your turn whoa oh my god he's fighting back well
he should have fought back harder if you didn't want to die
you should have fought back harder guys watch your footing
you don't want to fall into those lasers what lasers what
lasers what lasers oh these laser oh those lasers oh
Oh, those lazies.
Let me see if I can aim this.
Okay, we gotta do one more.
Is that not hit?
Ow!
Don't bother.
Where am I supposed to go?
Boop.
Alright, I'll grab this guy out of the way.
Follow the barriers.
Woo!
Oh, that's not fair!
That's not fair!
That is not fair!
I got confused
oh my god I made it I made it I just made it there's some
kids over there too
got the kids too
trace around the outside six to one there must be a way in
all right nice he was unaware whoops bye that was just for
showmanship that's for style points there all right what the
fuck they shoot back all right now i have to shoot you guys
oh wait he died first try all
right nice we made it see easy Yeah, I'm punching the air to
assert dominance.
Alright, there's no more misses.
Uh, because kids make me more money?
Oh shit, hey.
Why wouldn't I kill the kids?
I get more money when they're dead.
Capitalism, baby.
Where the fuck is the hole I'm supposed to- where's the
pressure point?
Oh, there it is.
There's the hole.
Whoa!
Oh, you thought an ambush was gonna get me?
Ha!
You think I was born yesterday?
All right.
Behind near.
Oh, okay, that's easy.
Oh, I did it.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I was thinking about it.
I was like, this is one of those.
Get out of there before it fucking blows kabooy, isn't it?
It's one of those missions, isn't it?
No!
Oh, God.
I can't!
He's so fast!
Raven, there's only two minutes left!
Oh god, oh god, he's so fast!
He's so fast!
He's so strong!
He's in the sky!
He's so much cooler to me!
Oh god.
okay there you go did you get it I got him hell oh oh I have
it okay
come on open the door open there I'm going to be so lost I'm
gonna be so lost I don't remember where to go I'm trying
don't feel me now
i'm going as fast as i could all right here you go am i did
i make it yay cool guys don't look at explosions look at
that we did it first try first try So easy.
You know what?
We're celebrating with finishing my chicken.
The corals near.
That's another solid milestone in our work.
Ooh, ah.
Oh, never just suck spicy mayo.
Whoa.
Wow, wee.
Hey, nice.
Yeah, money
Or next oh Do I have messages now I was the trip underground
how did they get reception the enforcement system silent at
least tried to take six to one with it good thing it failed
Well That deals with the PCA then What about the corpse
Archibus told us to wait before entering Terra incognita so
you're close then the corpse won't be helping each other
over the finish line yeah archivist wants bail them out of
the picture first looks like archivist is gonna win the race
no matter what come on short term maybe but i think 621 is
going to be the key in the end and that's why i shouldn't be
the one to choose which jobs we take sounds risky our
friends must be getting antsy Maybe.
But I think 621's got friends to worry about, too.
I'm not the bad guy.
I'm 621.
Alright, last cave mission.
Yeah?
You've got a request from the Liberation Front to go with
the order from Archibus.
It was sent by Middle Flatwell.
Just the guy.
He's the de facto leader of the Liberation Front.
Oh, that's the little weak-ass The retirement home guy.
She would actually retire.
The guy was so bad.
Man,
the reception here is crazy.
Registration number RB23.
Call sign.
Raven.
Your records have been updated.
S-rank virtual encounters.
Oh, nice.
S-rank.
In the arena.
Oh, that was them?
The best of the best?
Okay, I want to see who's rank one.
Okay.
Who's rank one?
Boyd.
Commander of the Vespal, the Arquibous Group.
Oh, it's Arquibous Group's augmented.
Achieve an astonishing 94.7 mission success rate.
We're gonna make that 93 soon.
Similarly, ordinary human being.
A man who enjoys piling in a city city city.
Oh, he's just...
Oh, he's just a guy.
He's just a guy.
Just like me.
I'm just like a guy.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, is this a choose one only?
Wait, I finished the cave mission.
That's why I got reception.
Wait a minute, guys.
The cave mission was over.
That was the last cave mission.
There was no more exploration.
also.
Is that in the cave?
Oh, shit, it is.
All right, we'll do one of them.
It doesn't split, right?
I can do both, right?
I thought, like, I thought, I thought that's why I got my
reception again.
Oh, it's a choice.
Okay.
Um,
choose one.
Eliminate Michigan, the red guns.
If I click on it, does it finalize my choice?
Okay, I just listened to the re-thing.
Or Rubicon or the...
But QueryBus has the rank 1.
Oh yeah, the Liberation Front is the Pussies.
Let's show a preview.
Alright, let's listen to the re-things.
This one's from the Archibus Group.
This request comes from our affiliate Schneider.
Schneider?
I could be hitting the next Schneider film if I do his
mission.
I'll brief you on the state of conflict between Archibus and
Balaam at Watchpoint Alpha.
Yeah, if I kill him, I'll be rank one.
The Watchpoint's defenses inflicted heavy losses on Balaam's
initial wave, with many deserting.
More recently, they've engaged with our forces only to
continue their downward spiral.
Despite this, the Red Guns commander, Gun 1 Michigan,
remains alive and well.
Liger tail being ready to lead the surviving Balaam MT
forwards as we speak.
I didn't give a super chat thing.
Thank you.
It would still be 234 of you when he just doesn't come 235.
Okay.
Should you decline, we have V4 lined up to take over.
Okay, which pays more?
This concludes the briefing.
Why don't they tell me how much it pays for?
Alright.
I need a...
Okay.
$400,000.
All right.
That one's $400,000.
Oh, a fucking $400,000, of course.
What the fuck?
Like...
Is this from the Liberation Front?
Yeah.
They don't have the money.
Yeah, they're indie.
They don't have the money, guys.
They're an indie studio.
Archibus leads the corporate forces.
emboldened by assimilated PCA technology but they're still
human tired from the endless conflict between powers on
their key forces we want you to eliminate mine company
officers oh it's two guys it's just two guys Hawkins their
officer overseeing the transport core V8 peter is agitant
we'll use phone information to lure them out from their
depth to survey then ambush them i will assist you on this
mission it'll be a good opportunity to catch up with a
veteran that's why it's like we're splitting the pay that's
why oh this is hard okay this one's just two guys and i get
i get a dual partner
I don't know.
Oh, is he doing it?
Okay, it's a 1v1 or a 2v2.
Wait, which one's the sad mission?
Because, like, this one's 400k.
Then am I going to use 400k worth of ammo?
1v army.
This is a Kingdom Hearts situation.
We'll have to kill the Heartless.
Let's see it.
Let's...
Alright, it's Kingdom Hearts time.
Just get it.
One fee a hundred.
It's like the... who would win?
There's nothing more for me to say.
Who would win?
One man or a hundred gorillas.
One sun-sized man or one or a hundred gorillas.
I'll have the ammo you know what doesn't need ammo this boom
oh shit maybe I need to start using guns
oh oh shit I missed oh yeah boom I ain't scared.
What the fuck?
Did that shoot me?
What the fuck shot me?
Alright.
I'm just gonna knife him real quick.
There we go.
That's fucking right.
Be scared!
Oh, you're scared, aren't ya?
No, boy.
You're so scared.
That's right.
Give me all that money.
Oh, shit.
Whoops.
Don't worry, I'll have so much ammo, guys.
Whoops, I missed.
Oh, no.
drones okay we gotta get rid of the little night get it off
like it fuck this guy
already to die
there you go look at that
and let me shoot them down for free
Well, I'll finish this.
I'll just stab him.
Boom!
Oh, never mind.
Get out of here.
I'm just gonna kill you right here.
That's...
Guys, don't worry.
I have plenty of ammo.
Don't worry, guys.
I have so much ammo for this.
Guys, do not worry.
Oh shit, wait, that's a real guy.
Wait, I need to stop PMing.
That's a real guy.
Get over here.
Get you...
Oh my god, you're not even part of this fucking fight!
Are you fucking kidding me?
Are you kidding me?
Wait.
Oh my god.
You get him out of here?
Are you serious?
I was right next to him!
Oh, no, I don't have this bad.
This is actually bad.
Oh my god, they're little babies!
Oh my god, the little babies fucked me over.
The little babies!
Ha!
We were so close.
It's okay.
No, no, no, no.
We got this.
No, they didn't eliminate me.
All right.
We gotta lock in.
Okay, die to the babies, guys.
That's fucking right, that's me!
Okay, these little guys are very annoying, though.
See how I can...
There you go.
Push the waves.
Yeah, I'm just gonna stab one.
And then...
Get the ship down.
And then stab!
And...
And then...
All right, we're good.
My build is good for everything.
My build is universal.
Can't say that.
I have a universal build.
What the fuck?
Okay.
This is...
There you go.
metal already sir we want someone nice they're good you know
i wonder if i can oh i can't the short range i don't know i
just got very hopeful
okay i'm gonna get that time guy what i'm gonna get that
time guy what i'm gonna get this time guy there we go
There we go.
We got the time,
yeah.
Oh, no.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh, shit.
There he is.
Where do you go?
Oh my god.
That's right, be useful!
Where is he?
Jesus Christ.
No, no, no, no, no, no!
You can't be serious.
Where did he go?
Where did this fucker go?
oh my god i can't see him i can't he just flies in the
corner like a fucking i'm so mad
i'll just kill him i'll kill him i'll kill him first
oh my god
oh why can't i use my thing
Let's get the little guys, I'm gonna get the little guys.
I'm just gonna kill the little guys first.
Oh shit, I might be running out of ammo guys.
Sure that'll hit my shots right here.
Right now.
God, he's such a, he's such a little bitch.
Actually.
Oh my god.
He's such a little bitch!
Oh no.
Make every shot count.
Oh my god.
I have to make every shot count.
I gotta start punching people.
There we go.
Oh my god.
Why did I do that?
Wait.
Guys, it's over.
Guys.
Me, Big Boom.
No, Big Boom is for everything.
Big Boom is universal.
Big Boom.
guys I'm gonna let future do this I guys we'll give it this
the future dokey future dokey this is future dokey's problem
this is I this is this is our problem I'm I'm checking out
I'm time-stamping checking out I'm good I'm I'm clocking
out, guys.
Hey, guys.
Before I go, tomorrow, we do have another stream tomorrow.
We're going to have World Cup.
We're going to do a watch a lot of Canada versus South
Africa tomorrow.
I think it starts at 12, right?
For them.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
One more try.
for him for i'm running i don't think i don't think that one
more try i don't think that one more try is gonna take us to
the promised land for him unfortunately um but before i go
streaming tickets i'm gonna make a tweet about it today uh
because in exactly one week left it'll be the dokey dokey
rewind time so streaming tickets will is still is out for
those who didn't get it yet link you the streaming tickets
but it's out now whoops wrong link got the wrong event link
is it this one there you go yeah so you guys want to watch
want to watch the concert online you can um the top right
you can set the language to english on the top right corner
uh right here for those who are wondering i'll do a little
tutorial it's right here i'll do a little arrow too Do
multiple arrows.
So, you're like, I can't read this.
Do not worry.
Here is the arrows.
The tutorial arrow keys.
Right here.
You see it?
It's right.
Right here.
You can turn it to English.
And then...
Right here.
Right.
There's like three arrows, guys.
But, yes.
watch the concert online um for those who want to check out
my dokey dokey rewind time um but it's 3 500 yen i don't
know how much that is in us to yen to usd um it's 21 guys so
thank you all for the support everybody i'm gonna head off
now me tired because there's gonna be another stream
Posture check get up and move around to get that blood
flowing and you said for me head to bed Cause you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye